well it's back to school time for much
of the world but the coronavirus has of
course made returning to classes a
challenge almost everywhere
we asked our correspondents around the
world to tell us how schools reopenings
are going on in their country
it was a mix of nerves and excitement as
the kids at this east london high school
headed back for the first time
since march the teachers here tell me
they're ready with staggered class times
social distancing measures and one-way
systems
but for the older students in particular
the road back to the classroom
hasn't been easy schools here were
reeling from a series of chaotic
government u-turns
which left many kids over the summer
facing days of uncertainty
over how their results will be awarded
for cancelled exams
and this new school year isn't bringing
back any more stability
teachers here say many kids are months
behind
on their learning their warning that the
knock-on effects could take their toll
for some time to come despite a new
search of coronavirus cases schools here
in spain are reopening these days
even if it doesn't look like it it's
actually a nursery school behind me it's
located in a beautiful old park
and i was very happy when we were
informed some days ago
that our son got a place there but the
happiness is now mixed
with a feeling of uncertainty the
government came up with a lot of new
measures some days ago
but schools haven't had any time to
react to it at least there's going to be
a parents meeting and some days
and we will hopefully find out more
about how our son's first days
of school will look like during the
pandemic students are back in school
throughout the whole of
china including wuhan where the epidemic
has started
students need to wear masks there are
social distancing measures
and staggered schedules but otherwise
schools are supposed to go
back to their normal curricula schools
colleges and other educational
institutions continue to remain shut in
india
but the government has allowed schools
to call back some of their staff by the
end of this month
for online classes and other related
work however comparative examinations
which take place in the country every
year continue to be conducted
despite protests by students and
petitions to the supreme court for their
postponement
here in uganda's capital kampala schools
remain
closed what you see here is a reflection
of what's happening across the country
right from elementary level
to university level classes remain
closed the government
is not sure of we need to reopen schools
now
especially with the rise in cases of
covet 19.
now many teachers have already lost
their jobs earlier on the government
tried to introduce lessons on radio
and television but sustaining that
became
a challenge so many families have
already described 2020
as a lost academic year
there is no one way of reopening schools
in the u.s
here in washington d.c schools like
francis stevens elementary
remain closed and students continue with
online learning at home
other states happily reopen their
schools but their
kids have to keep their distance from
each other and wear masks all day
that even goes for four and
five-year-olds in kindergarten
one mother has told me that she will
probably not send her daughter to
kindergarten this year because of that
with strict rules like this she says it
feels more like
prison here in beirut the capital of
lebanon
the covet 19 pandemic is not the only
crisis that faces the educational system
right behind me is an exhibit of a
school out of 160 that were totally
destroyed or damaged
due to the colossal beirut port
explosion while the school year
is only a few days away the destruction
that was caused by the shockwaves earth
explosion
aggravated the calamity on residents
already suffering from an unprecedented
economic crisis the german government
is ruling out a second lockdown
confident
that the current testing tracing and
tracking capacities
will be enough to contain the current
levels of corona outbreaks
in the absence of a tangible health
crisis and with the economy recovering
faster than expected
there's now an all-out debate here in
germany over whether the government
wasn't too
cautious in the first place a loud
minority
has been taking to the streets over this
nationwide
schools remain open but when it comes to
the question
which conditions like masks apply that's
still
regional patchwork
you